[Music]
big holes keep popping up and the
stories told by Michael Wolfe author of
fire and fury the alleged inside account
of the Trump administration Wolfe told
NBC yesterday that the 25th amendment
providing for removal of the president
by his cabinet was quote a concept that
is alive every day in the White House
and quote but then he had this to say
this morning did you speak with any
members of the president's cabinet for
this book I did not you did not I did
not and did you speak with the vice
president I did not
okay so we've had a little bit of a
guest issue but David Webb has kindly
agreed to stick around and join us again
and in our nation's capitol is David
good friend who's was deputy secretary
to President Bill Clinton chief of staff
now this guy never even interviewed the
VP never interviewed the cabinet
officials I don't think he ever
interviewed any of the first family that
he talked to Ivanka he talked to Eric
did he talked to Don junior because a
lot of this stuff does not ring true
David how much of this do you think is
just pure fiction oh this is why I don't
dive in the stories of palace intrigue
they're often way overblown and he says
he spoke in initially gave the
impression that he had spoken to
everyone that he had this unfettered
access he could walk around and maybe he
did for a little bit but you've been in
the West Wing I've been in the West Wing
it's not that easy to go in and out of
rooms and now we find out he can't
answer pointed questions these questions
were never asked before the book came
out they just took it as fire and fury a
trump administration in in its demise
going down in flames what's going down
in flames there's another author who
wrote another book that's salacious it's
like a bad soap opera except this one
won't be back in reruns okay
David the other David let me ask you a
question because I don't understand how
this makes sense the central premise of
the book is that Trump didn't want to
win the election so if he didn't want to
win the election why was he
colluding with the Russians to win the
election I don't get it yeah there's a
lot of kind of weird questions that pop
up around this book I'd be the first to
say that as well it kind of reminds me
when I worked in the Clinton White House
you had people who would leave the White
House and then write these expose books
which I thought was kind of betraying
the privilege of having worked in the
White House and I think here - we should
just assume at least I'm gonna assume
let's say 50% of everything in that book
is just flat-out wrong just write it off
50% of it we don't know which 50% but in
my view if only 50% of what's been said
in this book is real it is incredibly
damaging and all you have to do is look
at the president's own reaction you know
if somebody said something about me
that's a lie I blow it off I don't react
this president became the first
president in US history to pronounce I
am saying
really I am and that makes me think he's
protesting a little too well let me let
me tell you why the president has to say
something like that because if CNN MSNBC
ABC CBS and they all spend 48 hours
bringing up shrinks to say the president
United States is crazy
and then the president seats is asked to
respond to that the headline then
becomes the president defends his sanity
that's how the media plays these games
so that's exactly what we get it on Fox
News people said Barack Obama isn't
really a citizen of the United States
that was totally crazy now President
Obama didn't jump out and say I'm really
a citizen really am there you know I
can't name one person on Fox News that
said that what's happening eventually is
actually it's rising it's raising the
sales of the book now the book is
becoming a best-seller
precisely because Trump is talking about
well that's true that's true - now maybe
that's why Cory didn't come on the show
tonight because it maybe knocked his
book down a few rungs on the New York
Times bestseller list but it's so funny
to be called insane by the left who's
screaming at the sky who's wearing
wearing
yeah with genitalia you know Bernie
Sanders thinks global warming is more of
a threat than Isis if anybody's insane I
think it's people on the other side yeah
I mean if you look at this and I'm gonna
use a big word for the left now this
compendium of what's false and what's
true all these things they've said about
Trump and this is he delayed the the
fake news award so next week I don't
really care about that I care about
policy that's what I care about they put
all this stuff at him and then you
attack the man you attack his family you
attack his wife you attack his daughter
representative Cohen attacks an 11 year
old boy barren his son on Twitter what
do you expect a father to do he's gonna
defend himself when President Trump
became president he didn't give up his
right to say what's on his mind
no president ever has or does and
frankly I like a guys gonna fight
because I'm sick of the left yeah he's a
country lunch and the Republicans are
I'll send you guys a box of tissues you
go wow I want to play sound that's
coming in there's this new attempt to
undermine President Trump that's just
unfolding tonight he's at the college
football national championship this
evening earlier he took the field for
the anthem and he sang along but now
people are on the left are claiming he
doesn't know the words to the national
anthem all right so first we're gonna
show you the clip that's making the
rounds on Twitter and then we've got an
edited shot to show you from when he
sang the whole thing word-for-word take
a look well
so we had the try
/ leave me
[Applause]
all right so I don't know if you could
see the video there good friend but I
mean the guy he's singing along with the
national anthem and now the top trend on
Twitter is saying Trump doesn't know the
words to the national anthem I mean give
it a rest yeah so I actually looked I
looked at the video and I think
everybody should just so that you take a
look for yourself
and from my viewpoint sometimes he's
singing along and sometimes he's not
sometimes his lips are moving and
sometimes they're not I don't know if
that means he doesn't know the words
that way to jump into conclusion so do
you think the President of the United
States doesn't know the words and the
national anthem
no I just think he doesn't like to sing
probably I don't know the words let the
left assigns the value of he doesn't
know same it's what they did to Don to
our Reagan he's a dumb actor he doesn't
know what he's doing they assign these
values to people because if it's their
narrative just like they went out and
said the president was being vote being
booed so I listened to it I actually
watched it live and I rewound it and I
watched it and I rewound and I watched
it and I'm sitting there listening to
this going the first thing I said was
the left's gonna come out they're gonna
say doesn't know the words when they
know nothing it's like a psychiatrist
who knows he's crazy
but it's actually never talked to it
right well then there's no way that the
president United States Republicans
Donald Trump is getting booed when
Georgia is playing Alabama down in
Atlanta guys I got a run though it's I
got it wrong a Democrat to the Senate so
you got to love Alabama just elected a
Democrat Senate there's hope for them
yet
roll tide yeah